They've all had to move everything themselves over the new network, so it's been a lot of moving ah no it's it's great
we're so grateful to CBs for launching the show for putting Melissa on buildings all over the world and for all their support, but
We were all thrilled to learn about this because it's there's just there's something really nice we obviously do a lot
Greg Berlanti Andrew Kreisberg myself we all do so much with the cw. So there's just a real shorthand
They do you say metahuman they know what you're talking about?
So we're really glad we're just happy to have everyone in the same place
Literally and and channel [life] nice and now you're a members of the flower rovers
Yeah
Well are [we] have there is there any discussion yet as to how oh?
Yes, yeah, oh, yes, okay? It's very complicated and [I'd] have to kill you but no worry. It's we're super excited [for] the
Crossovers over all four shows it's Gonna be an incredible
all right, so
How did you swing getting superman for this [exit] next to them [I]?
Mean it's not um it wasn't hard and to be honest it [just] that in season one this shows about Cara
And it's about Supergirl and so that was a sort of confused matters a little bit to have Superman there
but now I think everyone you guys know her now right a
Sense of who she is and this show is about family
And it's about the family that you make as an adult and this family that's come together
And then it's also about the family you came from and clark is now now that Laura Benanti is full time playing Melania trump
we have clark to represent the
Family so I think it's only natural now that Cara reconnects with him all right, and I know this is a huge deal
This is massive, but this is Supergirl and it is about Melissa benoist
This has been such a great season for you
What great for people who didn't know you from Glee or anything like that? What a great ride? How has it been?
I'm
Just happy to have made it out alive
um
Guys, I like the last season
I don't I honestly look back, and I don't know how I i did a lot of the things that we did and I
Challenged I was challenged in so many ways and did things I had no idea. I was capable of doing and I
feel like I've grown so much kind of
simultaneously along with Cara
And we fell in love with the whole ensemble this year you guys gave us every reason to love them
Including David who we all thought he was a Baddie when he truman
At [what] point at what point? Did you guys all feel like a team?
There you they want around yeah
Yeah, yeah, and a pilot yeah
Yeah, sure
and
Did that make these the long hours?
And the you know the all the work and the physical stuff did that make it easier knowing you guys we're all working together on
this
Adam
Yes, [we're] a team who is the first to be like I don't want to get in the harness that
[was] me definitely was no pot. That was me. Oh I feel [I] [being] in the harness is different for a guy. Yes
Yes, yeah, but you have to decide very early. It doesn't feel good
I weigh 235 so that the harness is a little different. I chafe like that. It's more
Um are you so david you are you in the damn Martian Manhunter, whoa?
Martian Manhunter on television um and lastly or like I said we all thought this guy was going to be a villain
How was the you know kind of sitting on that secret and knowing that this guy was going to eventually go green well actually?
When I did the panel this time last year, I had no idea
I was gonna be Martian Manhunter, so it was a it was a great reveal for me
And it was just so so funny to look online the next day when he was revealed
To see all these videos of people just jumping up and down and screaming when he actually revealed himself as the Martian Manhunter
Was just awesome with that scene of your your performance in that scene?
I am I was so lucky to be in the room with him and during that scene
We make a [great] please impact. What we did
You guys really do you do you got I love this team and also Kyler I gotta say. I think you had chemistry with everyone
Living like every episode [of] that shit. I [crush] [it] like she hates jenelle. [I] don't think she liked james that much though. [oh]
My God you met you out a little bit cuz you know you're digging on the sisters
Hmm yeah, yeah, man. So where is Alex headed this year because last year also at this time
We didn't know that Alex was gonna be such a badass [wow]
Thanks
You know what's really cool about this season is
We've established so much about who Alex is in the de oh her
Relationship with jean and that journey and where that went from and then where it is now
and then her relationship [obviously] [was] with Cara and
Kind of established Alex that way, but didn't really get to see very much about her outside of those elements
And so this season is an opportunity for us to kind of learn a little bit more about her and [just] kind of see
Who she is what she wants?
Cuz now she's kind of in a place where she can sort of make those decisions a little bit and she's always
Always has taken care of car and since she's come into her [own] so much. It's kind of like okay
I have a little room [to] kind of
Maybe not be in the cave all the time maybe not even loft all the time where does Alex live
I have no idea. [I] didn't ever she's live in the hallway cuz that's where we always see her just coming into the apartment
She's like a dreamer yeah, I
Just skid in Jeopardy
nobody it is when the journey between you know John and Cara and and
Alex to figure out where Jeremiah danvers is if he's out there and what happened
And that's kind of like their unified Journey in a sense. Thanks alright and Maccabi you are ready for romance next season
Define ready and Define romance well last time. We saw you and Cara
Things were not platonic
yeah, we ended up in a lip-lock and
Yeah, yeah, long overdue
Yeah, and it's weird because I read the first I read 201 and it starts with our wedding so that's I thought it was
Yes
That is really fast. [I] think that's been rewritten [os] oh my dad
No, it's like it, so it's a workplace relationship. It's it's it's a new relationship. So it's gonna have up and downs and some
Tumultuous things and you know she's still finding out who she is as a woman
and I'm still finding out who I am you know, and I think that may get in the way a little bit too, so
We'll see what do you guys think?
Yeah, I
Don't even ask you yeah, specifically though, because I'm guessing he'll probably have to get clearance from Superman
We have we have we have some bro time to talk. [oh] yeah, we got a little bit. Yeah
There's some bro time coming over [-] [no] nice. No Jimmy a little bit
Jeremy so I my dream for when is that every season he falls in love with a villain [I]?
Want me good. I wanted to have like the worst tinder experience
This wouldn't really like vendor then cuz it's like villain for [this] [vendor] [vendor]. I like it vendor [dude]
I told it I call him - okay
Is there do you feel like this guy is perpetually going to be the one who's like what why?
Thank you in the in the romance to be talking about win, right yes. Yes
When I had those experiences earlier on um no actually no, I don't think that I mean
I think that would [be] really funny and maybe we'll play with that for a while
But um you know in in the first season
we saw when kind of go from this like meek unassuming completely unconfident guy to
You know meeting is finding out about cars powers
And through you know helping her and meeting all these other people and meeting James
and he sort of has come into his own and grown more confident and
I don't know. I think confidence is pretty sexy. So maybe he'll find some somebody a little ball [alright]. Oh
That bet that maybe won't break his heart
but I don't know I don't know but I also think you know it's it's
We thought we saw a lot of wins romantic escapades last season and and this season
I think we're gonna get to see you know when kind of reaching his full potential
Because he was he was an it guy at Catco when really he's this great computer genius
So we'll see him kind of using his skills in a more productive manner, [okay]?
well
That's what I wanted to follow up with those um
It is in addition to his bad taste in women he also has great taste in tech and when he ever he's in the de
oh
He's like a kid in [a] candy store. Do you think there's a possibility that he would end up moonlighting there?
Maybe me you know it could be
I mean, he's already I feel like he already has been moonlighting, so I think he's looking for a [straight-up] job
[all] right, [I] think it would make the deal a little bit more fun. [I] think so
Yeah, a little serious right now you think Johnny could handle [an] idea. I mean, that's a good idea
[yeah], we need some more laughter in the de oh yeah. That's a good idea. It's pretty heavy all right so Mr.
Hoechlin yes, Mr.. Tyler Hoechlin
This is not a minor character. This is an icon and you have gone now from wolf of teen
to a man of [steel]
What is this like finding out? [oh], they've picked me to play Superman
um definitely incredibly surreal
[it's] a it's very I don't know I I know the the character represents so much to so many people
I was um
I was with a friend who was
With his mom and his mom's boyfriend and he came up to me and was had these like I had to shake your hand out
To shake Superman's hand and that [was] kind of that weird moment of oh, it's it
This is not like a generational thing. This is literally something spread across so much time
There's a responsibility to that character
So that's something that I take on with Great pride
And you know [I'm] just excited to kind of see what we can do with that character in this
Great world these [guys] have created in this first season, so I'm really excited
Have you uh have you have you tried on the suit yet? I have not tried on the suit yet
Yes, that will be that will be a moment for sure, but he looks great in the halloween costume, right?
[other] [places] it was a onesie uses pajamas. I tried it on [it] didn't fit
And then I tried it on I ripped it in half okay. I have it. I have a theory that when literally just has
backups of every superhero costume that he just puts on
And sits around the house
There's certain things that Cara has gotten involved in as have alex that clark might not be down with
Such as the killing of astra things like that. How is he going to like what brings him?
I mean, I don't think car was totally down with the killing of Asheville in fairness uh yeah, I think that they did
Clark has a very different experience of what it means to
Have superpowers on Earth and he was raised with them and with certain values. So there's definitely
some real kind of head buddy and philosophical approaches that are different, and we'll get into all that and
The other thing I just wanted to say those you know Melissa Benoist is
also, a Superhero and she's so
Hard-working and so sweet and so nice
And it's so nice every time any little girl or boy
Comes to meet her and we're all just so lucky that we have an actual
Supergirl playing Supergirl here
All right, so let's talk about some stuff that's coming up in season two because there's a lot of chatter. There's a lot of
Rumors assumptions hopes, you've got Maggie sawyer coming on yeah. God for Iana life. So what?
What is the story there because we know that?
He is connected to that woman. There's all that stuff going on. What can you tell us?
I will say did she's an incredible actress and really tough and a real badass
And I think one of the things that we're really proud of is having a lot of strong
Badass ladies on television, and she's going to be another one all right, okay um
My second man is she uh is she going to have people in her life that we could possibly look forward to
Well, everybody is somebody in their life come on
Does that person have a mask ah?
No, okay um maybe we can get them on and then you uh you have in Gomez
Yes, who's so fantastic? He's Gonna play Snapper Carr and
He is he came in and he really does this sort of like well this reference will not mean anything
But he's like [very] lou grant [hmM] for any the five people here. That know what I'm talking about
Eventually they'll remake yeah, what's great? Is that?
I think you guys watch the show a lot of people really respond public even cat responds really
Positively to Supergirl even if Carla drives her crazy like everybody likes Supergirl or Cara
Usually but not not ian he really could not he doesn't fall for either of their tricks
Which is really [gonna] be a lot of fun?
And then this is this is so great Lynda carter as the president of Lynda carter is the president
Like first of all I want to know why is the president getting involved?
Because big things are happening you. I mean big [things] have to have a good superman and Supergirl together, okay?
So what what should we [expect] from this president wonder woman well? I think we should expect that a female president is Gonna lead well
We're with her. Yes [are] [with] [her]
Hashtag yes, all right, and then the big one
Which is like the mystery box that they're selling out on the floor?
[these] you can bite like $20 you get a box and it's filled with like a bunch of stuff
So we have Chris wood's coming on
as
Mystery or surprise DC character yeah, can you tell us about this? I mean [do] you guys want to know?
[or] [do] you just [do] want to just wait until the [show] airs maybe I don't think they care very much. [I] mean
Maybe if they knew that he was in the Pod, oh
Mm-Hmm. Well what would that imply, then I don't know with so many things, but yes, that's there's there's the big answer
Reveal he's that he's the the hottie in the potty
really funny
[funny] guys to be hash tagging that once you come on
all right, so
Now that you guys have all worked together for a year except for Tyler. [I] want [you] to look to the person to your right
and
Tell me tell us one thing about that person. You've learned
Mm. Does it mean I get you damian. Yes, are you?
I've learned that Damian [hland] does the best moderating a panelist, okay?
That's going on my reel
So Sara go ahead
What if I learned from from David well?
I think that we all knew David was a great actor from his work on Homeland and various other things
[but] I I don't think we realized how truly
phenomenally talented he is I love that and
and also that
Apparently everybody even the brits like it when he does an American accent as he does in the night manager if you haven't seen it
I
Learnt that [Kylie] really is a total badass. [she] is
In fights in just all her application. [I] just think she's probably one of the best actresses that I've ever worked with
He's only saying that because I actually punched him in the head once it hurt [for] three days
wow, I
Don't think I don't think we have enough time for me to really talk about the lady to my right I?
Have learned
the definition of
Grace
by [this] one I
mean for someone in her position to Handle
This whole famine this whole thing so
gracefully
And [so] tastefully and she's so kind but not only that I mean even just sitting at the table reads
When she's reading the script the first time I'm reading it out loud, [and] I'm just watching him like she's so good
[like] I just and then I'm like I think I'm doing an awful job, but so good
No, she's just you you are you are a lovely human being and I just am so grateful that [my] little girls
get to look up to somebody like you [and]
she's just
inherently
Good
What to say about my God [I] can't wait, I'm nervous [you]
[know] what I find. I have learned that you are always full of like the natural remedies
He's always got some like tincture or potion or like oh
What did you bring to set that one day? Uh Paulo Santos that yes?
Which smells really good, but you also brought deer antler yeah?
Something that was made from deer antlers and they always are like
Obviously like natural and you you helped me out of a lot of binds so I don't know that. He's the medicine man
um
Medicine [man] talking um what I've learned about Jeremy JJ, Jordan?
The things I could say about this man
what I will say a
Couple things I was like uh he honestly is one of the best actors I've ever encountered in my life
Really? He's one of the funniest people I've ever encountered in my [life] and
also, one of my favorite and
It's a joy to come to work every day see his
smiling Smug look I
Don't know how you can be how you can smile be smug at the same time, but he's [pulled] [it] up. [I]
Love work. I love working with all these guys
It's it's very Jason Priestley [it] is but it's amazing and I love this guy
I love I love the entire cast but Jeremy. I have a lot of work together, and it's just a joy
Thanks. Yes, wait. You're right. [I]
Guess I have to say something by you Tyler who I met sorry [four] days, [okay]?
Yeah, you just [take] [a] shot take a guess. It's fine. It doesn't have to be true
Just just make him laugh. That's fine
What if I just [think] so I just stare adoringly at you fer
[know] I mean I've known this guy for for less than a week
and I could already tell he's probably one of the nicest most genuine guys I've ever met uh
He's got he's got just the loveliest eyes
He just he just does that one [unbuttoned] just enough just
just a tease and
And and I know he has he hasn't tried on the costume yet. Come on what?
you're talking about but
This just became to wait there are we can [we] see you know what kent can you do the curl?
Look the hair cream. Yeah, do it?
Do it do it do it? Yeah?
I
just wish I would just wish that shooting the show is Gonna be fun because it's
The worst time you guys bro trust me
Okay, we're gonna go to audience [questions], so you guys want to start lining up
I have a couple of quick ones [um] Melissa
I always ask you what what glee songs do you have on your iPad or iPod?
But now I want to know Jeremy which smash songs do you have on yours uh?
I can't let go by Jennifer Hudson man. That was my Jam
All right
Okay
And David Ramsey said yesterday on a panel that he cannot wait to cross over
Have you guys considered how you can get John diggle from Star City to National City?
Yes, yeah, yeah, they have
you